what's going on guys this is Rob and in
light of James Gunn's announcement about
the authority being a film that DC
Studios is producing I figured we will
cover volume one The Authority does
exist in DC Comics at this point in time
particularly with Superman and the
authority but it's a wholly different
team separate from the one that we're
going to see in the film hence the
reason why we're covering this story
instead of Superman and the authority we
will cover that story it's awesome it's
really really cool but we're going to
kind of cover the origin of the
traditional Authority team first so what
this does is this initially opens up in
New York City and it picks up with two
people the first one is Jackson king and
the second one is Christine trelane now
here's the thing about these two
characters then being introduced is not
arbitrary the nature of authority is
that it's actually a follow-up team it's
a secondary team the team that came
before Authority was a team called storm
watch and the idea behind storm watch is
that they were basically a team
sanctioned by the United Nations as a
combination of a protective Force as
well as an offensive Force against
whatever threats May endanger the world
in a capacity that they were needed but
also in a humanitarian capacity in the
sense that like they would help other
nations if they needed it or something
along those lines but thing of them is
like the Justice League if the Justice
League was sanctioned by the United
Nations and operated on behalf of the
United Nations now the original storm
wash team is by all standards the
measurement basically dead right they're
or at least defunct Jackson and
Christine were part of the original
storm watch team and because the team
doesn't really exist in any capacity
anymore you do have kind of like Jenny
Sparks we'll talk about her here in a
second as well as like the engineer the
shaman Apollo a few other people but the
thing about this is that Christine and
Jackson in light of the fact that storm
watch doesn't function anymore they're
basically they've been relegated to like
sitting in an office and monitoring
threats across the world and like that's
basically it right they're they're not
really doing anything anymore and to a
degree for Jackson it kind of drives him
crazy because he misses the days of
being out there in the world protecting
it from various threats but the reason
why this is so important is because as
they're monitoring an attack that had
just taken place in Moscow where
literally some force of all these people
had just flown in and obliterated the
place and so in that moment as they're
basically monitoring everything they're
met by the arrival of Ginny Sparks now
for the most part they are aware of who
Jenny Sparks is just because of the fact
that you had the main storm watch team
and then you basically had what was
their Black Ops wet work team Ginny LED
that team right like the clandestine you
know CIA type of spy team kind of thing
you know the ones that operate under the
radar and like kill people just like
that kind of group right so Ginny Sparks
and Christine and Jackson are well aware
of who each other is but what had also
gone on here is that with Ginny Sparks
having her own team that what's
essentially happened is that with the
main storm watch Team going defunct
Ginny's own team still kind of operates
out there but what Genie is basically
doing is not only grabbing her original
team but adding new people to it in
order to form a new team which they'll
now Rebrand in calling it Authority so
the best way to hit about this is
imagine you have like the main Avengers
team right in Marvel Comics you got
Captain America Thor the Incredible Hulk
all that kind of stuff say that like
Captain America had The Secret Avengers
a secondary team that was out there that
was basically a Black Ops Team they
would carry out missions where I know it
sounds very unlike Captain America to do
but to basically strike it people from
the Shadows which is kind of what he did
during Civil War right now imagine the
main Avengers team goes defunct by
whatever Manner and whatever means
Captain America takes his Black Ops
sweat work team his secret Avengers team
adds a couple people to it renames it
and then goes forward as a protector of
the world that's basically What's
Happening Here With regards to Jenny
sparks's own storm watch team so what we
end up finding out here is that the
attack on Moscow was led by a guy named
Kaizen Gamora who is actually at one
point was an enemy of storm watch what
he's doing here the entire basis behind
him doing all this is twofold one
because he's just a villain and a dick
and two because he's trying to get
revenge on the world for what happened
with storm watch that when he was
defeated the United States United
Nations basically sanctioned him
effectively cut off his country from the
rest of the world and in response to
that he's launching attacks against
other parts of the world basically his
revenge and so the result of this is
that once once the authority begins to
realize what's happening they're not
entirely aware of everything going on it
really is just kind of Jenny Sparks
meeting with Swift and meeting with Jack
in order to basically say we need to
start putting together a new team or
bringing together this team adding a
couple more members and then going
forward from there now something to know
is that Jenny Sparks and the authority
operate out of a base of operations
called the carrier and is basically a
vessel that's always on the move so
they're never in any one particular
location strategically it's a smart
decision because no one ever actually
knows where they are but the other
reason why this is a big deal is because
when it comes to really when it comes to
Wild Storm in the DC Universe in general
that it's a little different from Marvel
and the sensitive Marvel Comics you have
like other dimensions right you have
like the dark domain mentioned where
dormammu hangs out at you have the
dimension of Asgard where Thor and Odin
and all those guys are and DC Comics
it's a little bit different a dimension
is a place that's slightly out of phase
with the main universe meaning that with
the carrier they can sort of enter into
a different dimension and in doing so no
one can see them and no one can track
them they by all standards of
measurement make themselves invisible to
anybody outside of those individuals who
can like manipulate magic I know it's a
little a little wonky and it seems a
little strange it's the easiest way to
explain it without going into overly
complex things like hyper time and like
the bleed and all that kind of stuff we
will talk about the bleed here in a
little bit but the reason why this
matters is because as this conversation
is being had between Ginny Sparks and
Swift there's a couple things to know so
really when it comes to Jack he can
basically interface with a city right he
can literally communicate with an entire
city directly the buildings and
everything and by doing that he knows
the strengths and weaknesses of the city
but he can also see everything that's
happening in the city at any particular
point in time that will become
instrumental here when it comes to Swift
she's not that dissimilar from hot girl
in DC Comics and that's one of the
things that you're going to realize here
is that these different members of The
Authority are basically stand-ins in the
Wild Storm Universe for traditional DC
Superheroes it's one of the reasons why
despite the fact that jack isn't really
immersed in like witchcraft or sorcery
or anything like that he in a lot of
ways Bears a striking resemblance to
John Constantine right outside of just
the constant cigarette smoking the cloak
right the the overcoat and the suit and
the whole nine yards he looks like John
Constantine but what ends up happening
here is they actually send Jack out into
the Moscow Remnant in order to
investigate the city and see if they
can't pick up on some Clues regarding
how this happened and why because they
don't know Kaizen Gamora is a part of
all this and so of course as Jack gets
there he ends up coming across this
symbol on a building which basically
indicates that it has something to do
with whoever it is that's launching this
attack you don't read only see a giant
symbol like that out there following
this Ginny goes to visits the engineer
now the engineer is a cool character but
she's not the first one the reason why I
say that is that there was an engineer
in the Wild Storm Universe before the
one that we get here the difference is
that this engineer is a girl who
essentially was contacted by the
original engineer who basically gave her
all this information and all this data
just because of the fact that this girl
was obsessed with the idea of merging
humans and machines together but what
she ended up doing was actually merging
herself into a machine essentially by
liquefying all that information all that
data that was given to her and then
turning it into her own blood there is
an origin story about her but again it's
it's different right it's different from
what you're traditionally used to when
it comes to superheroes that's the other
thing that you're going to learn is how
these folks gain their powers for
example Jenny Sparks was born at The
Stroke of Midnight in the year 1900 she
can manipulate electricity but she can't
create it so it's uh there's a they're a
little finicky in terms of how they gain
their powers and different things like
that now at this point we switch over to
the doctor also known as the shaman and
this guy kind of pulls themes from a
variety of different sources some of
which are it's really not even pulling
themes it's more using themes to
understand how he functions for example
in a lot of ways we can use the Black
Panther Mythos to explain the role he
has while black panther was just a
character out there in Marvel who was
part of the Avengers and has been around
for decades it wasn't until you got to
the Jonathan Hickman run of the
Fantastic Four that you learned about
him becoming the king of the dead and
then learning or at least using that
ability to communicate with his
ancestors the shaman is very much the
same way that much like Doctor Strange
he is kind of a quote-unquote sorcerer
Supreme and I use that term very Loosely
here I use that as a way to just sort of
compare the two roles and to give an
easier understanding of the the purpose
he serves but in effect he is a
protector of the world and uses magic to
do so but he's part of a very long
lineage of people who have done that so
he's only the most recent one if and
when time comes when he dies a new one
will be chosen and they will become the
new doctor and so again that's why you
see him communicating with those that
came before where it's literally just
him understanding what his powers are
his ability to manipulate magic is
massive in scale although over the
course of the authority Comics you'll
become more and more Adept added and
really more and more sure of himself
which will allow him to tap into greater
levels of power but I say all that to
say he's arguably the most powerful
member of the team and so following that
we switch over to the other two
teammates midnighter and Apollo now
these two guys are exceedingly well
known in the DC Universe just because
they were the standout stars of wild
Storm's Authority right they were they
were really the more popular ones here
um truth to tell that when Wild Storm
did Authority while it wasn't
necessarily part of the main DC Universe
it became part of the main DC Universe
during the events or after the events of
Flashpoint when Barry Allen screwed up
the universe and then DC used it to
merge Wild Storm and DC into a singular
continuity right into a singular
universe but midnighter and Apollo have
always been a really really popular team
and even a really popular couple because
they're actually in a relationship
together it's one of the things that we
didn't readily know when the comic first
kicked off but it became pretty obvious
in pretty short order that these two
guys were in a relationship but it's
funny because they kind of bicker like a
couple does in a relationship but in
effect they're kind of Batman is
Superman right and in fact in Superman
The Authority or Superman and the
authority there's a character named
Manchester black that has the ability to
cast Illusions when he meets her at
least when he comes across midnighter in
Apollo he refers to him as like the
world's gayest right which is kind of a
funny thing because they're like I mean
basically yeah like I mean you got a
problem with that Manchester black go
over like there's the door right there
get out
it's pretty cool how they just kind of
own it you're like they step into their
own and they celebrate their
relationship and so what this does is it
really kind of puts them in the position
of kind of Being Batman and Superman to
a degree not exactly Apollo has a lot of
Superman's powers he's not as strong as
Superman is midnighter is very
comparable to Batman but he's not
exactly like Batman so there's small
little differences here and there but
the long and short of this is the group
is basically trying to figure out what
was going on with the attack in Moscow
when out of nowhere an attack happens on
the city of London they learn about it
it was basically the 11th Hour meaning
they're really too late to get there in
time to stop the attack before it
happens they get there and they
basically deal with the attack as it
happens but of course them arriving on
the scene allows them to pretty much
take all these different guys out of
course it also gives us a display of
what their capabilities are in the case
of the shaman he basically uses his
powers to actually transmogrify one of
the uh one of these you know super
powered clones essentially by turning
him into Birds right like literally
turning this guy into birds and his body
just kind of falls apart as it becomes
Birds it's pretty wonky and pretty wild
uh one of the things we learned about
Jack for example is that yes he can
interface with the city but he also
becomes stronger the bigger the city is
London is one of the biggest cities in
the world so of course his strength is
proportional to that meaning he punches
one of these guys heads off and then of
course we're picky we pick up with swift
who just like uses their super strength
and flight to carry these guys away and
tear them to pieces and then Ginny uses
her ability to manipulate electricity to
kill a bunch of these guys so again
that's when we're kind of given this
display of what the team is capable of
and what it is that they can do but
still the bigger issue at hand here is
why was London attacked after Moscow and
who's doing these attacks right what's
the basis behind all of this and so when
the team is able to overcome these
forces and at the very least save the
city of London from complete and total
Destruction one of these soldiers
teleportation device is basically
destroyed by Apollo and when when that
happens he's forced to fly back to
Gamora Island to the base of operations
of course Apollo decides to follow him
in order to get back to where he's
coming from and basically bring it into
this whole conflict or at least gather
information that can be relayed to the
rest of the team the problem with this
is that once Kaizen realizes that like
there is a new superhero team out there
that is wildly capable and was able to
stop his attack in London he basically
creates a kind of force field Dome over
Gamora Island that keeps them safe from
everybody or every every other threat
that's out there once the authority
realized this Force feels there and
Apollo's on a collision course they
quickly deduce that if Apollo flies into
this force field despite how capable he
is it'll kill him because seemingly no
being can penetrate that force field now
of course this leads to the shaman
basically using his magic to slow Apollo
down this super powered being who's
flying towards you know the superpower
clone that's flying towards the city
basically he's traveling too fast he
doesn't have enough time to stop he
tries but he ends up becoming a stain on
the on the dome right literally just bow
like crashes right into this thing and
that's the end of him now something
that's particularly interesting here and
this was when we basically got this kind
of continued explanation of wild Storm's
place in relation to DC Comics the way
in which the doctor was able to slow
down Apollo was by basically teleporting
him to a different universe that allowed
him to continue going until he could
slow himself down and when they do have
a momentary reprieve and the question is
like where in the world are we that the
the doctor kind of gives this little bit
of an explanation where he talks about
things called the bleed and so on and so
forth so in DC Comics and really is part
of the larger Multiverse while Wild
Storm is in a different Universe than DC
Comics although again that changes and
that will change with James James Gunn's
film that the bleed is what separates
the different universes so if you treat
every universe as a brick in a brick
wall the bleed is the mortar in between
the bricks right that gray stuff that
goes in between the bricks and holds
them in place that's how that works so
again it's just a little bit of an extra
explanation there but a lot of new
readers really kind of came on with the
authority and so it was a way to sort of
refresh its place within the greater DC
landscape and so while the authority
kind of plays a humanitarian role by
sort of rescuing people who were trapped
under debris where authorities can't get
to them and so on and so forth once
their efforts are basically done and
it's just kind of left to basically
various emergency crews in order to deal
with everything that's left they kind of
go back to the drawing board trying to
figure out again who's launching this
attack and why but that's when they
start to realize these guys are
basically coming from Gamora right
they're coming from the island of Gamora
and when they realize that Ginny Sparks
in particular realizes it's the home of
Kaizen and that he's literally launching
this attack for what seems to be just
Petty Revenge at the same time that's
happening that uh Kaizen realizes that
Ginny Sparks and the authority are above
Gamora Island and so he realizes while
it's not necessarily storm watch it's a
newly relaunched team that basically
functions almost exactly the way storm
watch did and so that's when he's kind
of trying to pick up the pieces or
figure out why is it that they're
unifying in any meaningful way the uh
the team of storm watches disbanded it's
defunct it doesn't exist anymore so what
in the world is Jenny Sparks doing and
why is she forming a new team I mean
it's obvious why because like this guy
is attacking the world and a team like
storm watch needs to exist to protect
the world from different threats both
inside and out because there is a point
where Earth is attacked from an
alternate reality and the authority
literally steps in to protect the world
during that conflict it's pretty cool
it's called shift ships it's actually
volume two it's a really really cool
story but the thing about this is that
where you get a kind of normal display
of villainy from Kaizen where he
contacts like the United Nations and
it's like I'm gonna attack the city of
Los Angeles because I can and there's
nothing you can do and this is because
you guys attacked me and defeated me and
my people died and so on and so forth
just regular villain stuff right nothing
really unique or interesting about him
what it does do is it allows the
authority time to figure out how to to
infiltrate Gamora Island and take down
the force field and in fact it's
actually midnighter who basically pulls
it off and while midnighter is able to
enter Gamora Island through a portal
what that does is it allows him to work
from the inside and then hand
information off to the rest of the
authority while the authority itself
focuses on the new attack that's going
to happen in Los Angeles information
that they were able to deduce and figure
out once they get there and they make
their way through La what ends up
happening is of course the attack takes
place now this attack happens while
they're basically trying to figure out
how to fortify positions potentially
evacuate people so on and so forth and
so this leads to the team jumping into
action yet again while simultaneously
midnighter is working within Gamora
Island to understand how these forces
exist in the first place and a way to
bring the place down now what he ends up
realizing as the attack takes place
within the city of La what he realizes
on Gamora island is that this entire
superhuman Force that's being used by
Kaizen are all basically clones they're
engineered right they're designed to be
super powered beings and a massive Army
and so as he makes his way through there
of course he ends up meeting Kaizen and
what this guy basically does is kind of
taunt midnight or two degree telling
there's nothing he can do he talks about
using a bioreactor kind of using energy
itself or kind of a limitless source of
energy on the nuclear level in order to
power this entire facility and keep
these clones basically developing
endlessly because so long as this
facility remains intact clones can be
developed forever right so really it
just turns into a war of attrition how
long can people possibly hold out for
how long can the military hold out for
but in the taunting of of Kaizen towards
midnighter and him talking about how it
literally is an endless endless supply
of clones that it can go on forever
because it has an immense power source
that's what gives midnighter the idea
that the the Dome is not impenetrable an
object with a strong enough force or a
high enough level of durability can
destroy that force field and so what he
does is as he teleports back to the ship
when he teleports back to the carrier
and then Pilots the carrier directly
into the force field itself and when he
does that it not only destroys the force
field it wipes out the entirety of
Gamora Island literally just obliterates
it destroys the facility the whole nine
yards kaizens killed and all that kind
of good stuff when that happens of
course the Clones the Clone Army that's
being used in the city of Los Angeles
they're readily defeated as well but
ultimately the day's saved right the
story wraps up pretty fast like it wraps
up incredibly quickly and so the way it
ends is it's really Jenny just kind of
communicating to the rest of the world
through what is a kind of massive
transition via the United Nations
meaning the team is now sanctioned by
the United Nations that they are here as
a new team to basically protect the
world to keep the world safe from any
and all threats that exist out there so
yeah that's the origin of the authority
that's the origin of this team as it
exists in DC Comics so let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace